[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here today I want to
share with you my favorite leg exercises
which helped me to tone up scar my legs
burn fat and even get rid of cellulite
so this workout is really short and
intense only 4 exercises for mates long
20 seconds of work out with 10 seconds
rest interval no equipment needed at the
end of this workout I can assure you
your links will be on fire so be sure to
start with a quick warmup
here are the workouts so let's get our
muscles ready and get online ready try
to give your best push it as hard as you
can and really give it your all
I'm going to set my timer and let's
start with the first workout which is in
an hour squat so sue squat and pop in
okay ready in three seconds let's go
squat touch and hop it good so why to
split up squat back in good huh darkness
20 seconds keep going make sure you come
to the floor
good and pace your breathing nuts few
more last one ten seconds better so I
can work out good take squat jumps
okay so squat down and rotate it to the
back ready
let's go squat boot a squat squat
well and release the legs to push it
rotate good rotate good take it away do
you want
well most nice good
no that's what jobs this would really
work on the outer thighs get ready
whoa go go let's go no I just like and
just you see at the same time
good one more second best final break
your jumping lunges okay really push as
hard as he can jump for up chops which
did switch very good well it's unity and
I can feel my legs burning you keep
going do you want
push you don't stop right now back to in
and half squat
hoping good one
helping stay strong I'll be there
rip out when it's tough piece of
breathing okay strong legs - okay
let's see what we got let's jump to your
outer thighs and you pump cheeks down
rest final write down Charlie - feel
like you wanna give up don't
let me see yourself keep going guys keep
pushing lunch lunch oh my god oh my god
guys I'm still trying to catch my breath
that was only four minutes long but my
heart rate is off of a room that is why
I like of these exercises if you're
sweating and breathing hard like me be
sure to LIKE this video if you're
feeling strong take a one-minute break
and repeat the entire workout once more
do this workout two to three times
weekly on alternate days and in four to
six weeks trust me you will see and feel
the difference on the bus for new
fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
you